[Gelächter]
ist schon wieder
ja es tut mir leid ich wollte jetzt hier
eigentlich nur so ja ich habe mir ja so
lustige Holzfäller fails angeguckt bei
tiktok wirklich super witzig aber jetzt
auch schon wieder 8 Stunden rum ne ja
dann lass mal kurz drüber reden soziale
Netzwerke oder wie wir stolzen
Absolventen der Karsten Maschmeyer
Hauptschule sagen Social Media im Jahr
2023 ist Social Media so ein bisschen
wie Wasser Luft oder Markus lands
ständig um uns herum 4,8 Milliarden
Menschen nutzen soziale Netzwerke das
sind mehr als ZDF gucken ja kann man
sich gar nicht vorstellen also zumindest
nicht beim ZDF und was ich viele auch
nicht vorstellen können wie schlecht
Social Media wirklich ist und ich weiß
ihr denkt jetzt wow wann ist 750
geworden und ja ich habe mich noch nie
so alt gefühlt aber zu meiner
Verteidigung möchte ich sagen ich sag
das hier nicht als Lehrer mit erhobenen
Zeigefinger ich Schimpf auch darauf weil
ich selber nicht dosieren kann ich stehe
mit Instagram checken auf ich gehe ins
Bett mit insta das hier ist meine Screen
time am Handy von einem zufällig
ausgesuchten Tag jetzt mal
juni das sind sechs Stunden 47 Minuten
und drei Stunden vier sind davon Social
Media und wir wissen dass Social Media
nicht so gut ist aber es hat sich längst
noch nicht bei allen rumgesprochen wie
schlecht es wirklich ist bei Social
Media ist es so der Kampf um die
öffentliche Meinung verläuft wie früher
bei Zigaretten in den 50ern gab es hier
unter Studien die nahelikten dass sie
krebserregend sind und dann fertigten
die zigarettenkonzerne eigene
unabhängige Studien an die sagten nee no
way Zigaretten sind gesund haben wir
rausgefunden es brauchte Jahrzehnte
beharrlicher Forschung bis klar wurde
Zigaretten töten und es brauchte dann
noch mal ein paar Jahrzehnte bis die
Politik gehandelt hat bei Social Media
sind wir gerade in den 60ern mehrere
Studien sagen Social Media führt zu mehr
Depressionen und wie damals die
zigarettenkonzerne sagt Mark Zuckerberg
der Chef von Facebook allen Ernstes nee
die Leute fühlen sich viel mehr
verbunden ja verbunden mit ihrer
Depression sagt nicht ich einmal
Facebook selber der Konzern hat über
Jahre eigene Studien unter Verschluss
gehalten denn Fazit ist Instagram macht
depressiv schadet den Körperbild vor
allem von Mädchen und jungen Frauen und
löst Angststörungen aus einige Studien
zu dem Thema kommen zu dem Schluss je
mehr du Social Media nutzt desto größer
ist deine Chance depressiv zu werden
wenn du Instagram sehr häufig nutzt ist
ein Risiko depressiv zu werden dreimal
so hoch und es gibt vier Faktoren warum
Social Media so schädlich ist erstens
der soziale Vergleich es ist kaum
möglich sich auf Facebook Instagram und
tik tok unter anderem nicht mit anderen
Menschen zu vergleichen dein eigenes
Leben kommt dir Scheiße vor warum räumst
du eigentlich gerade die Spülmaschine
aus wenn du auch in Slomo aus dem
Helikopter springen kannst und dann
riesigen Berg runter Snowboard ist
während sich hinter den Lawine löst was
los mit dir du opfer da kannst du dir
zehnmal sagen dass es nicht die Realität
ist im Schnitt sind Jugendliche von 12
bis 19 Jahren in Deutschland jeden Tag
und dre Stunden online wenn du
dreieinhalb Stunden am Tag online bist
und gefilterte Menschen siehst ist das
dann eben deine Realität Jugendliche
sehen im Schnitt 5000 Bilder die Woche
so oft kannst du gar nicht in die Sauna
oder ins Freibad gehen um zu merken ah
ja so sehen Menschen realistisch aus ich
bin übrigens gerade geschminkt so sehe
ich einem schlechten Tag aus ja nein
Spaß ich sehe dann so aus wann immer ihr
euch hässlich fühlt seid gewiss irgendwo
da draußen ist till Reiners und seine
Mischhaut feiert ein Fest
also
zweiter Faktor der Zeitaufwand
dreieinhalb Stunden am Tag
durchschnittliche Nutzung sind mega viel
das ist ja nur der Durchschnitt ihr
bleibt nichts mehr fürs wirkliche Leben
und was hast Du die letzten Jahre so
gemacht ja ich habe einfach viele Leute
mitgeteilt dass Ihre Bilder gut finde es
war mir wichtig die Zeit habe ich mir
gerne genommen 1985 als ich geboren
wurde haben 14 bis 29-Jährige pro Tag so
oft Medien genutzt fünf Stunden 30 also
330 Minuten wenn 10 Minuten ein
Zuckerwürfel sind sind es also 33 bei
euch mal schnell nach die Zeit nehmen
wir uns
und noch drei
2020 haben Jugendliche und junge
Erwachsene 8 Stunden 20 Medien genutzt
also 500 Minuten 50 Zuckerstücke ich
hätte ja mal eine Sechs in Kunst ne und
jetzt hier bin ich mit ganz ehrlich
Freunde und streng genommen haben
Jugendliche sogar 10 Stunden und 20
Minuten Medien konsumiert weil sie
mehrere Medien gleichzeitig nutzen
Harald kannst du dann noch fünf dazu
stellen
[Musik]
also gemeint ist ihr guckt im ZDF die
heute-show und auf dem second screen
guckt ihr andere geile Angebote in der
ZDF Mediathek zum Beispiel also
so stellen wir uns das beim ZDF
zumindest vor Nummer drei die
Reizüberflutung und klar gibt es auch
Studien zu wir uns Reizüberflutung
depressiv macht aber brauchen wir doch
gar nicht alle die schon mal 3 Stunden
crap bei tiktok gesehen haben wissen
danach denkt man sich nicht oh das Leben
ist schön du bist leer und überflutet
von Eindrücken und schon 10 Minuten
später weißt du nicht mehr was du da
eigentlich drei Stunden lang gesehen
hast es ist traumloser Schlaf du tauscht
Lebenszeit gegen den Geschmack von Glück
aber es macht nicht satt bisschen wie
Kartoffelchips wenn ich die esse ich
immer erst auf wenn mir schlecht ist
aber ich bin noch nie davon satt
geworden und da wäre noch die Sucht nach
likes unser Körper ist auch einfach nur
dumm der Schütte Glückshormone aus wie
nichts gutes nur weil Moni 43 unser Foto
gefällt in dem wir so tun als hätten wir
ein geiles Leben und das wollen wir die
ganze Zeit wiederholen wie so eine Ratte
die immer wieder auf dem Schal ter
drückt und dann kommt so Zuckerwasser
aus dem Haaren bis die Ratte Diabetes
hat der Erfinder des Like Buttons
Vergleich den mittlerweile mit heroinen
witzig
all das ist schlecht für uns macht uns
aber irgendwie süchtig und wenn man das
alles weiß warum gibt es nicht
wenigstens ein paar Grundsätze auf die
wir uns einigen können erstens warum
gibt es nicht viel stärkere Auflagen für
die Apps dass man die zum Beispiel nur
eine Stunde am Tag benutzen kann und
klar das kann man bestimmt umgehen aber
es gibt ja auch die Gurtpflicht obwohl
es leicht ist die zu umgehen aber alle
merken durch die Pflicht ah es
anscheinend wichtig das mit dem Gurt
zweitens als ich zur Schule gegangen bin
gab es ein großes Problem mit Komasaufen
ein Grund waren alkoops es waren so sehr
süße Mischgetränke meistens mit Wodka
die haben nicht nach Alkohol geschmeckt
aber richtig reingehauen perfekt für
Kinder große Diskussionen gab's der
verkauft wurde durch eine eigene Steuer
deutlich unattraktiver gemacht social
Media wird doch ähnlich warum behandeln
wir Social Media nicht wie alkoops und
drittens warum gibt es immer noch
Schulen in denen man sein Handy benutzen
darf warum ist es nicht obligatorisch
dass man sein Handy für die gesamte Zeit
die man an cool ist abgeben muss so dass
man lernt ja ich komme auch vier bis
acht Stunden ohne Handy am Tag klar
warum gibt es nicht in ganz Deutschland
ein Fach
Medienkompetenz wir setzen uns die ganze
Zeit Medien aus und lernen nichts
darüber dafür fangen wir ab Klasse 7 an
mit Buchstaben zu rechnen
Kurvendiskussion hieß das und wer da
Bock drauf hat ey Leute macht das gerne
zieht durch aber mir ist danach nie
wieder eine Kurve begegnet mit der ich
diskutieren wollte um es noch mal
zusammenzufassen jetzt so als
Matheaufgabe für die Freaks da draußen
rund 9 Stunden am Tag Medienkonsum
gelernt in der Schule darüber habe ich 0
Sekunden dafür aber sechs Schuljahre
Kurven Diskussion gesichtete Kurven bis
jetzt 0 wie lange dauert es bis in
Deutschland gehandelt wird das wäre
jetzt die Textaufgabe wütende
Mathelehrerin und Lehrer schreiben gerne
in die Kommentare
hilft alles im Algorithmus
ja okay die endcard ist jetzt ein
bisschen schwierig hier sind wir ehrlich
miteinander also ich weiß streng
genommen ist YouTube jetzt auch Social
Media das ist etwas komisch wenn ich
sage dass ihr euch bitte doch super viel
Videos angucken sollt und ähm ja liken
ne wegen dem wegen der Sache mit dem
Heroin aber Leute ey ich bin nicht
besser als ihr ich will einfach likes
bis ich mich wieder spüren kann außerdem
es muss auch noch jemanden geben der
sich in den Medien über Medien aufregt
und was mich interessieren würde ist
nutzt ihr Apps zur Reduzierung von
Social Media oder wie schreibt ihr euren
Konsum ein postet das mal hier drunter
interessiert mich wirklich und welches
Thema interessiert euch über das ich mal
ein Video machen sollte lese mir alles
durch versprochen danke